grown-up gamers are flooding the
marketplace as they hunt for the video
games of their childhood and as Kirsten
Joyce reports The Hunt is driving the
price of those Collectibles to new
heights
these days more and more gamers are
gaining wealth not by playing by
collecting I really started collecting
when I was around college and I've just
been kind of going strong from there
Jonathan Nichols works at 8 news now as
a web graphic designer but in his off
time he's a connoisseur of vintage video
game my grandmother bought my first
gaming console for me as Super Nintendo
when I was around four to five years old
and I've really been gaming ever since
it's the memory the Rarity the hunt that
fuels his passion the favorite things
that I collect are Super Nintendo and
Playstation One games there's a
community of grown-up Gamers that look
to acquire the items that made a mark so
many years ago and when covet hit a
renewed interest in vintage games to
Colt during the first year of covet an
increase of 37 percent in spending
across video game Hardware software and
accessories the competition got Fierce
for collectors during the past few years
games that I thought would probably go
down over time they've just continued to
increase since of things that that are
in my collection are the Super Nintendo
games games like Earth own if you have a
complete collection now or upwards of
three thousand three thousand or more
dollars every hobby has its enthusiastic
collector who'll pay ridiculous prices
for rare memorabilia in the world of
video games this often means wear
cartridges limited edition merchandise
and long lost artifacts from an era
before anyone knew how big gaming was
going to get some games even fetch six
figures the identity of those buyers not
well known if I had one that was worth
hundreds of thousands I would probably
sell it but for collectors like Jonathan
who have cherished these games and
memories a lot of them are just
sentimental to me they're things that
I've played when I was younger they have
a lot of nostalgic values it's harder to
cash out he'll hold on to the memories
instead